[Music]
let's face it women love flowers they
also love sex but sadly I can't help
them they're the pills don't work
the point is I'm gonna help out today on
Valentine's Day by delivering women
flowers I chose this place in Sherman
Oaks
it's called Mulberry row they said that
let me help out and clearly no one cares
more about Valentine's Day than these
guys they have a lot of romantic
Valentine's Day gifts in this shop for
example this poodle who's clearly ready
for sex
there's lotions and creams here's
something every guy wants on Valentine's
Day a tape measure Robin you were one of
the co co-owners of this wonderful store
and I want here to help oh good thank
you tell me what you're doing right now
cleaning the tulip cleaning the tulip I
was caught in Catholic school for
cleaning the two little I'm gonna tell
you women something that's gonna be hard
for you to believe when I was in my 20s
I had trouble meeting a girl
it seems pretty funny now
ever say are they makeup flowers do you
ever get those oh yes one guy this was a
few years ago we knew that he had
cheated and got caught and you know it I
think it was like $60 with the flowers
too and I told that wasn't gonna work
the rule is it has to be five times what
you spent on the hooker do you put me to
work I think I'm a good worker what do I
do
yeah make this romantic and lovely okay
look what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
this
[Laughter]
okay I got it there please
hey I said wear a lot of sunscreen so
your that's putting you off right now
well then you don't like the sunscreen
smell well sorry it was nice for you or
get cancer
can I read some of these notes happy
Valentine's Day thank you for being in
my life I don't love that do you a lot
of people are in your life my
accountants in my life
hey how you doing I read your note your
note says happy Valentine's Day thank
you for being in my life
you were driving when you wrote that
yeah that's not good you can tell
because you can see the first draft is
thank you for being in my life
hey I think I can merge now do you think
things are gonna get romantic tonight
hopefully can I add a little thing about
we're headed to the bone zone hello sir
what's your name
yo see ya you'll see tummy is for a nice
to meet you what kind of name is that yo
si yo si is a kind of Jewish name Jewish
name yeah like you Joseph it's like an
Israeli name right yeah are you from
Israel yeah my wife likes you so much
Oh terrific crazy book okay you like
quit wife crazy that's nice I always hit
the ladies man not so much so it's good
yeah yeah like to get both of you in the
tent but that's okay
so you'll see ya from Israel
yeah why are you not coming to Tel Aviv
I'm very busy here in America yeah I
entertained hundreds of people I'm good
that's millions no millions watch but
hundreds are entertained oh you see are
you gonna stay on the card yo see this
is important what are you gonna say in
the car I'm gonna say that them another
very much you love her very much that's
all you're gonna say well let's add
something I love you very much more than
you love Conan because she left tell me
what I want to say that yeah I love you
very much more than you love Conan
you're gonna say and then I'll find look
what she texted when you told her that I
was in a store I'm gonna deliver these
flowers to her Wow we can make okay but
don't tell her I'm you can't tell her
I'm coming
[Music]
okay I'm not making this up absolute
true story
these flowers are going to the wife of
mark McGrath the guy who was was he on
is on extra access extra base off Rudy's
in Sugar Ray you know all around the
world statute
[Music]
okay listen my question is this is a lot
of flowers for Valentine's Day this is
expensive or I'll tell you something
you're a problem with Valentine's Day on
Christmas I give my wife a gift she
gives me a gift okay Halloween I get
some cash where are you now the tines
day I get [ __ ] so what are you getting
for your life - Valentine's Day :
every year I do the same thing I give my
wife a photograph of myself and I write
on it you're welcome you get the
happiness and then I sleep in the garage
about six weeks
[Music]
this is it yeah this is where she works
you've been here before hello
is Mary here he's man
is Mary here Mary happy Valentine's Day
from you Oh see there's it for you
[Applause]
anyone
Yosi command man I wrote this car for me
[Music]
[Applause]
flower shop and Yossi and Mary for being
such good sports Happy Valentines
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]